Evangelista winds it around along the railing
and here is Ryan mcdonut hits the pass it'll give
him go sistens cuts to the net back to mcdonut
straight away a shot handled there by bris you
saw that number right there as Mason's pointing
out dominating at even strength most of the game
is played at even strike now here's that Top Line
forberg a quick release good save by bris horberg
trying to pick up where he left off two goals on
gold Friday in St Louis horberg gets turned around
runs right into one of the Jets and it's picked
back up Peter Ryder grinding along the boards
against MCD Mason Athletic who's played very well
on this third line This is a key line for the Jets
this line was excellent against the predators
in Winnipeg they also had an excellent game in
Florida against the Panthers they swept the two
game series on the road in Tampa in Florida here's
a tip by Josh morresy and it's handled by SOS the
third guy they got for Pierre Luke DUIs in that
trade with the Kings is Alex aalo number nine he's
been good too yes he has playing on that Top Line
with shyle and Conor here is thomasino ripped
it from the slot save made by bris might have
caught him on the mat the stick that was being
extended and get a shot on goal get to see Tom
thomasino involved early Brendon Dylan feeds it
away to Nikolai eers a shot from the wing rebound
sent wide by Vlad nikov see the second line here
another sneaky good line headed up by eers it's
a very familiar name to Predator fans and nikov
who's been around the block and young Cole Peretti
here's nikov on the rush eer swings it across
Peretti drags got the shot away and a good save
by Saros Peretti ends up in the net forsberg takes
it the other way that was a great save by Soros
tough situ ation coming to the middle and then
goes against the grain short side SOS all over
it watches eyes if we get the replay on that one
p into the glove of Soros and he'll slow it down
Pace picking up here in Nashville that be tough
but good to she she's doing well right now the
family Jets working around the perimeter off the
one draw they're building momentum Samberg to the
net trying to tip it with Neer Rider and soros's
able to handle it we got sber slamming up at the
point right there they've got traffic in front of
the net and SOS is seeing it right now guy's doing
a good job just let ju see the puck he's going
to nullify any opportunities there and there's
Nino NE Rider in front of the net as always but
Saros had good position connected the dots he
was able to get out to the stick blade in case
of a tip because the defense did a good job of
letting him see that shot from the point there's
a blast right off the face off by Dylan Dello it
makes it gives us a chance to tell you a little
bit more that was a game in Winnipeg where Andrew
rette thought thought his defense got pushed too
far into the crease and that made it very tough
on SOS well it's tough you Retreat as a goal
tender when you can't see the puck your natural
reaction is to retreat to the goal line because
it gives you that security blanket when in fact
it's just a defense mechanism that doesn't work
you want to get out you want to see where that
shot is coming from when it's coming from here
we go a third chance and three Saves by SOS a
fourth save another one goes wide and a diving
block by Yosi is blocked by aalo which have 10
shots on goal right now we're not even just over 8
minutes in well they got about five in that last 4
seconds it seems like now here's Conor to the net
that got through Ashville not crisp right now in
the first half of the first period Lowry trying
to get three to a shoulder from McCarron behind
the net they work it out to Samberg into the
traffic save made by Soros Appleton Circle has
to be careful the Jets tried to jump the passing
Lane siss open on the right wing dumps it in on
the cross Corner Evangelista takes over there
nice passino save and again the Jets are able
to protect the house for the rebound Here Comes
Connor hook checked Away by Yosi Connor and Yosi
arrive in the corner carier still out there
able to find trennan trennan lifts it through
the air patrolling at Center Ice Mory got roped
by McCarron Yosi picks up the loose puck rebound
score it's yo credit [Applause] again and a man
of the people and watch him he came to the bench
and he said let's go and right here trennan Wide
Open scores the goal Roman Yosi gets it to the
net off broas toe and Tran makes no mistake and
right there to the people he goes one nothing PR
and to Johnny Holmes was zambon Drive I thought
they did a good job there with the recovery got
an angry Jets team out there right now crossy
feet broken up last minute by the Predators and
a chance to counter Here Comes Sherwood with
wheel drops it off Yosi got a throw [Music]
score bris was surprised the puck comes along
the ice and Roman Yosi has a two-point night
well I think everybody in the building was
surprised here keeper Sherwood does a good
job getting that puck on the boards Yosi
comes in and picks it up and you can see
the body position of brat his body's not even
Square to where that first Power Play of the
hockey game for either Team Mist gets it
to Yosi and Nashville sets up y see two
points already tonight playing catch with fors
where got caught to the high SL back to score
Gus Nyquist sneaking in to the back post and a
beautiful pass by forsberg sets him up the power
play with a quick strike and Philip forsberg
it looks like another point for Roman Yosi as
he passes that to forsberg and then forsberg
gets settled disguises that pass through the
seam to Gus Nyquist on the back post and look at
this redirect no chance for brois right on the
inside of that far post group toughness here is
thomasino three Jets around him thomasino waits
for reinforcements he's able to find O'Reilly
O'Reilly back for taso Save they rebound Force
break is there Barry shot is blocked popped up in
the air he has on himself to do the right things
at all time whether it's at a pregame skate or
in the game is impressive what a goal there by
Night Quist bridgstone the official Tire of the
Nashville Predators here's morresy on a loose
Puck up the ice sends it across to a diving play
rebound scored McDon blocked the pass but it went
back to morisy and just like that the Jeffs trying
to change the tune they're on the scoreboard to
put home the garbage but watch right here MCD back
little bit of an odd man situation two on two here
but watch have done a good thing here oh and he
just he just slides right by com back to morisy
what a play there by MCD and unfortunately Saros
was going across and couldn't quite get all the
way back Frozen and Morris he just chips it in he
did a really good job keeping staying inside and
as heers came up and was trying to get the inside
the stick just got caught in the skates you got to
get that stick out of there open man Connor make
it Peretti and two goals and less than a minute
the Jets are right back in and they're within one
a power play goal Cole perect [Applause] F we get
a good look here Peretti 91 top of your screen
in this pass that's a beautiful pass down low
and then Peretti right on the off the inside of
the post makes a perfect shot and Juice we got
the Close Quarters pass now the Predators have
to hustle back on deep fet is gained the Zone
pushed it to the boards by Trenton along the
wall and into the corner healer centering PR
what a save soros's clued it along the ice battle
here gets a puck the mennik off in the corner he
comes out left-handed shot he's going Far Side
glove and you see soros's connecting the dots
and ab that got it back to Center the Jets tag
up 6 seconds to go one more chance elers looking
for a pass to the net shoots it's blocked and
the prors have won their fifth consecutive game